so I'm gonna talk to you guys about what
is DevOps you're gonna have a lot of
repetition now from which Serena's been
saying so you're gonna have to live with
us very thorough very thank you for that
so why do I think I can talk about
DevOps so for the last couple of years
I've been working very heavily in a lot
of places helping people understand what
DevOps is I've been helping implement
DevOps culture in Singapore government
agencies I've been in banks I've been
with a bunch of startups I've been with
a bunch of people so that's why I think
I I can talk a bit about DevOps so my
background is that I am primarily a
back-end developer doing a bunch of
things but I worked in a bunch of
different themed teams and because of
that I become one of these known
full-stack developers meaning that in my
case I know a lot about doing backend
work and I have a rough idea of how you
do things on the front ends I can muddle
it through so what that means is also
that I have a pretty good idea of what
it means that all of the other people in
the stack that I'm working on is doing
like I don't fully understand it but
I've gotten a lot of empathy for what
did it is that it goes into what does it
mean when you're dealing with influx or
with react or whatever that is like I
don't understand I don't have to but I
understand there's a lot of work to it
and empathy is key because DevOps at the
end of the day it's all about culture
it's a culture that everyone should be
working together and the the point there
comes in to that we're developers we are
operations people the sysadmin scouring
away figuring out what discuss the
drivers aren't working on a Saturday
morning because something went bananas
it happens business people figuring out
that yeah the increase in tax isn't
meant something now we have to change
everything new feature has to happen
really fast it just goes on QA is so on
like we all have to work together but
what does it really mean that we all
work together and what are we trying to
achieve by working together well what
we're trying to do is get our code into
production because what's the point of
writing code building the software if we
people aren't using it we need to get
people to use the stuff that we build
preferably as quickly as possible that's
why we have to
to help us out with that and we should
do it too much quality as possible
because what's the point of releasing
bad software to people that want to use
it that's just gonna lead to frustration
frustration leads to people leaving
terrible for customers to leave you
because I like their money and the day
right but so how do we go about actually
achieving these things because what we
want to do is that we want to have
quality how do we get quality well you
write some tests TDD I'm a big a July
despite what it might look like hey it's
okay I'm me so practice TDD is my key
thing I would recommend everyone to do
it's just gonna make your life so much
easier especially when you're trying to
go up all of these agile practices
really comes into play DevOps is a
culture of also taking care of this it's
all agile in the end the other things
that comes into now we start talking a
little more what people generally talk
about comes to DevOps provisioning so
what does that mean well it's pretty
much things like you get your servers up
the things that you used to do once the
thing that you just get written down
that yeah we got a server someone took
two weeks off and they installed it and
now we have it working please don't mess
with it too much
it's gonna be fine so create databases
maybe you need to do some database
migrations get your schemas up-to-date
do some migrate migrations for like
actual data and so on you know all of
that stuff then you also need to make
sure that you have something you can
actually run and you want to also have
the ability to go back to it sometimes
in the future so if I do an appointment
on my test weren't perfect they're
probably not I'm human after all they're
they're never gonna be a hundred percent
tests are always gonna be about what you
can cover as a developer at point in
time when you're writing it that's what
we do pair programming as well because
that will help us better see a different
point of view and having the playable
artifacts will help us get things out
quicker and back again when they go
wrong and of course automated
appointments because we can't get our
stuff into production
fast unless we know we can have it can
happen at a click of a button or even
better automatically and the thing they
can notice about all of this is that
this is all about what people do like
pretty much this is all about like the
things that we need to get done to
actually make it happen but how do we
actually do that and the way of that is
it's tools of course it's always about
tools in the end like we can't talk
about culture but which is the important
bit it's about the outcomes but we do
need tools so we have tools like ansible
chef puppet which is like the thing that
you install some kind of agent or you
log into a server it will install this
package that package configure nginx put
the party on hold whatever it is that's
what you have that's a good tool to have
in your belt if you're doing that maybe
you need to create a easy to instance or
connect to the Google cloud and need to
give them a server terraform fantastic
tool for positioning infrastructure tell
it that I want a server it's gonna be
this big it's gonna be 10 of them
they're gonna be named like this so it
works great together with ansible you
can get that configured the way you need
it takes time but that's pretty much
what it is a lot of people these days
are using container orchestration which
is more like kubernetes Makhno mad or
ECS from amazon these tools are all
about containers it's all about making
sure that you can get your code take
that artifact put in a container run it
somewhere generally when you have it up
and running it's a lot less work than
doing something like ansible and so on
so I would if you if you're starting out
look into that I'm a song together with
their Fargate is really no frills way of
going about it if you want to look into
it then you want to probably look at
cloud provider api's maybe there isn't
some particular tool that fits the bill
exactly for you each organization is
different maybe you have specific
deployment scenarios you have to care
about knowing that you can use connect
to their api's and do-it-yourself is
very powerful and really empowering
which also comes in two custom scripts I
personally do a ton of these at one of
my previous gigs I wrote something like
40,000 lines of bash if it it was a
particular deployment scenario involving
12 service three data centers and the
government I begged for Pearl which for
those who know the question that also
becomes how do you know that you need a
tool oh well apparently I forgot to
enable the thing that makes it only do
one at a time so yeah so did it take a
little effort to do something so yeah so
a lot of the ways people go about this
is that well it's really complicated to
get the oldest automated tooling I spend
a day doing it but it only takes half an
hour to do it manually take some
screenshots it's all done it's good yeah
but if it's runnable code you know that
if you're on it again you can see when
it works documentation just stays there
and the tendency with documentation
especially with screenshots is that it's
taking with a version that version was
changed one and a half years ago one no
one is updated and nothing works anymore
and names have changed everything
runnable code is always a winner the
code is documentation as it were make
sure everyone does things the same way
like in my company we have a deployment
process we want everyone to follow like
obviously it happens through CI but
before we had CI up and going because I
came in late we had to do it from our
laptops and having that checklist of how
to do all the steps now rather have a
script it can check all all those things
and it does it much better than I do
because I get bored easily so much much
better um what do you do when well this
you which hits the air what generator
has to say
do you take two weeks of downtown or
your business standstill or do you just
spin it up again maybe we'll take half a
day it's what it takes
it's one of my previous gigs one of the
we had that happen every week we took
down one of our environments run it up
from scratch so everything was still
working and sadly almost every week
something went wrong because we didn't
think about the fact that we aren't
always starting over from
good known state we have to start from
nothing and it's really valuable to know
that you can do that and I will admit
that right now this will not work in my
company in my team because I haven't
spent the time fixing that I will get
there I'm working on it
you need tools like it's important the
tools are important but at the end of
the day if you're talking DevOps it's
not about the tools it's it's about the
people doing it and it's also important
to think that just because you're buying
things it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're getting the story behind it and
also just because a tool is big in fancy
and because everyone is using kubernetes
does it mean that it's the best choice
sometimes maybe the best tool is
something you make yourself doesn't have
to be that big maybe you figure out that
like for instance I have a service in my
company that figures out what is the
next what's the next version I should
use for the thing that is built we have
20 odd services when they get a version
number yes I could build something and
put something on flask or on scene on a
track and get it up and running
also using Amazon they have something
called dynamo DB and if I use the
ominous tone CLI I can just ask them to
give me a number and it does works great
it took 10 minutes best spent time ever
still running so to give an example of a
deployment scenario when you have this
kind of automation which I said running
on CI CD it's cuz it all comes down
there it's the base place with a lot of
these things happen at the end of the
day because you don't want it to happen
on your machine but for the sake of
argument let's assume that you start
there so the way my deployment process
starts with a run all of my tests to
make sure that everything is green I
don't want to make sure I push something
that's wrong
the reason I have this in the script is
because we have multiple code bases
using many different things different
versions of Python lots of setup it's a
lot easier if I years don't have to care
about exactly how that happens it's a
voice check list then I want to deploy
this this particular thing on to staging
I don't I just want a new version I want
you to build this thing for me since I
know that my tests are green
please do that but what goes into that
so you build a deploy package that goes
into my artifact repository and I can
then pick it up later and I can roll it
back occur is that central database for
a number to use so that we know who can
refer to it later so when we say that
deploy 27 failed we know that it's toys
than 27 everywhere if I deploy I build
27 in staging and I say that I want bill
27 in production it's the same package I
know it it's fine I don't have to worry
about drift and especially important
that hopefully you also have all of your
dependencies in your package so you
don't get stung stung by that because
that can be annoying yeah uploads
package repository for archiving deploy
it
notify monitoring environment so we know
that there has been a deploy if we start
seeing anything that's a little bit odd
maybe we can tie it back to that we
deployed something because I said test
they're still at the end of the day
written by humans we're gonna miss
things we don't think about everything
it's what it is
so to recap what I have talked about is
so DevOps is a culture about
collaborating with other stakeholders
who they are depends on where you are
and what you're doing at the end of the
day it it's your your situation that
matters
it's about ripping a code running as
fast as possible with as high high a
quality as possible somewhere so people
can use it you want to keep the cycles
as quick as possible that's what you
really want so whatever is not it's
tools it's like you don't buy DevOps I
don't around all of strong opinions
about this the closest thing you come to
buying DevOps is the help of getting it
set up by a good company like Mavericks
but that's it and DevOps is not a person
it's something that you as a team do
like you don't want to be in a situation
where there's one person that knows
what's going on this is an effort that
everyone should be involved in everyone
should feel responsible for your build
if it goes red you're going
fix it if if nothing is happening you
have to take up as a team to work on it
so the idea of hiring a DevOps engineer
to do DevOps it's like having a
collaboration person that does all the
collaboration but in fact it's a
ridiculous notion and the as a final
point on tooling is that saying that
you're doing DevOps because you bought
some tool it's like saying that you were
a developer because you use vim
I mean first off no it's Emacs secondly
it's it's all about the outcomes it
doesn't matter if you it doesn't matter
where the code comes from as long as it
works and that's what we all should care
about and remember that when it comes to
getting things out you should know where
you're coming from you should make sure
that you have your fundamentals right
you work on your tests you work on your
design patterns you work on how things
fit together I need to work on how to
work to the product because the
delivering [ __ ] faster just gets it
messy and any questions